you've been doing Fox NFL Sunday show
for a long time and you become very
popular in the NFL so much so you were
awarded a high honor you were asked by
it was it the Seahawks yes yes it was
who was it it was coach Carroll coach
Carroll go see how I asked you to come
and entertain the team was this like
during tryouts this was yeah during
their OTAs which is their kind of this
the training camp they do in the summer
where they look at new talent and people
it's a tryout right so they they said
hey Rach would you come up and do comedy
for these athletes that are gonna be
trying out and that would seem to me
like kind of a tricky situation it's a
terrible situation it's an awful
situation to do comedy yeah
I don't know if this was a while ago
when I was still doing stand-up I
haven't done stammer a while but when I
was still doing it I did a charity event
here in LA make la better with Will
Ferrell yeah yeah and Pete Carroll it
was kind of their thing and so anyway
coach saw it and liked it so he said
come on up so I did he wanted me to
entertain the the players at 7:30 in the
morning before practice yeah these guys
are have been in training camp they're
exhausted they're beat up they're
they're stressed out about trying to
make the team and I'm supposed to come
in and give the yucks at 7:30 no this is
people who don't understand how Comedy
Works dazzle them with the yolks and
whatnot go kid go so what did you head
it
how did it go I was terrified first of
all I was like I got what am I supposed
to do for these guys that I didn't want
to do like my club act you know so I was
like I can't do that so I was like I got
to come up with something so I got there
that morning and I'm big enough that I
could maybe pass as a player maybe so I
said I told coach I said introduced me
because all the new players that showed
up at camp had to get stand up and give
their testimonial about who they were
like right I'm Bobo from Alabama and I
play this is my dream shut up yeah so I
said introduced me as like this
journeyman from the league right tell
them I played Canadian balls some NFL
Europe you know I'm a punter yeah you
know and and I I played all over the
league and and I'm trying out for the
team I'm I'm a lot older but I have some
wisdom and you really ought to listen to
what I have to say
so he did he got up there gave this
whole great intro I came up from the
back so no one really saw me but I was
in sweats and I was just just like them
so as I walked up about two or three
guys recognized me and they were like
all right some other people just like I
don't know this guy looks like a punter
from he's an old punter yeah so I got
there I was like all right guys great to
be here thanks a lot coach looking
forward to you know a shot at the team
real quick before we start show of hands
how many guys have an anal sex it was
that golden moment I got a 10 it was
that moment because the guys that knew
me were like diesel and the guys that
didn't were like I had one of my you see
buddy UCB buddies come with me so he was
a plants in the back and right when I
did that he yelled out he goes wriggle
wriggle was it what he goes he was
that's the high school speech man
[Laughter]
man yeah and then I went into I went
into all the do's and don'ts of the
league and just made up a bunch of stuff
it's just not saying yeah and then coach
said all right dress up we're going out
for practice and I was like well not me
obviously ya know you're coming you're
getting a Oh trying out so I was like
not pads because I'll die and he said no
not pads so I went out but I ran bag
drills and I got to I got to have a
workout and an official tryout with the
Seattle scene that was so cool
[Applause]
you